und damit kommen wir zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt der geht es um das
Wirtschafts- und Handelsabkommen ceta
das ist nämlich seit 2017 nur teilweise
in Kraft seit 13 Jahren gibt es ja immer
wieder Verhandlungen über dieses
Abkommen zwischen der Europäischen Union
und Kanada da gab es viel Misstrauen
viel Zweifel vielleicht erinnern Sie
sich noch an die Debatte über die
chlorhühnchen die so befürchtete man nun
die deutschen Supermärkte bevölkern
würden die Idee ist ja natürlich bei
diesem Handelsabkommen die Möglichkeiten
für den Handel und für die Investition
zwischen den EU und Kanada zu steigern
ein besseren Markt Zugang für Waren und
Dienstleistungen zu generieren und klare
Handelsregeln zu schaffen aber man hatte
eben besonders auch in Deutschland Angst
das ist mit diesem Abkommen
abgesenkte Gesundheits- und
Umweltstandards geben könnte eine
Politikerin die damals übrigens
2006 16 war das dagegen demonstriert hat
ist mittlerweile unsere Außenministerin
Anna-Lena baerbock lief damals bei einer
der größten Demos gegen das Abkommen
ceta und ttip mit mittlerweile sind die
Grünen da anderer Meinung und zwar in
Form von
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck der
hier auch schon in dem
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
auf der Regierungsbank sitzt die Grünen
haben es geschafft das Umzug
formulieren wie sie nun esceta sehen
dass sie sagen Globalisierung kann
stattfinden wenn sie fairer und
nachhaltiger werden kann und deswegen
hat auch Robert Habeck gemeinsam mit der
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Katharina dröge in
einem Papier sich ganz deutlich für Sie
da ausgesprochen und Katharina dröge
wird nun hier auch die Debatte eröffnen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gestern war ein
großartiger Tag wir leiten als Koalition
ein neues Kapitel in der Handelspolitik
ein eine Handelspolitik die Klimaschutz
und Nachhaltigkeit endlich in den
Mittelpunkt der Handelspolitik stellt
und nicht wie es in der Vergangenheit
passiert ist als anhand betrachtet
deshalb war es so wichtig dass das
Bundeskabinett gestern entschieden hat
aus dem energievertrag auszusteigen das
ist ein historischer Schritt Deutschland
kündigt den klimaschädlichsten
Handelsvertrag ab gehen die Europäische
Union jemals abgeschlossen hat es war
völlig absolut das deutsche Unternehmen
die Niederlande vor einem
internationalen Schiedsgericht verklagen
konnten weil die Niederlande den
Kohleausstieg beschlossen haben es ist
völlig absurd gewesen das wattenfall vor
einem internationalen Schiedsgericht
gegen den deutschen Atomausstieg klagen
konnte damit ist in zukunftsschluss
wir haben uns in der Koalition auf eine
umfassende Neuausrichtung der
Handelspolitik geeinigt und in Richtung
der CDU weil ich mir ungefähr vorstellen
kann was Frau Klöckner die gleich nach
mir spricht sagen wird das geht wenn man
sich zuhört das geht wenn man die
Argumente voneinander ernst nimmt und
nicht Spur mit dem Kopf durch die Wand
will wie die Union das in den letzten
Jahren praktiziert hat sie haben in der
Handelspolitik in den letzten Jahren
nämlich einfach gar nichts hingekriegt
mit der Ampel geht es jetzt voran wir
haben uns darauf verständigt auf
europäischer Ebene zuzustimmen als die
Kommission den Vorschlag gemacht hat das
künftig Klimaschutz und Nachhaltigkeit
mit einklagbaren Standards versehen
werden das ist etwas was vor einigen
Jahren nur die Grünen und die
Umweltbewegung in Deutschland gefordert
haben jetzt wird das gemeinsame
europäische Realität und dass man solche
Handelsabkommen vereinbaren kann das hat
die europäische un schon vor kurzem mit
Neuseeland gezeigt und es ist richtig
und es ist gut dass die Kommission das
neuseeländische Abkommen zum
Goldstandard ihrer Handelspolitik
erklärt hat
wir haben
auf der ansagt mit dem alten System der
Schiedsgerichte ist Schluss deswegen
haben wir uns darauf verständigt
Investitionsschutzabkommen Zukunft nur
noch dann ratifizieren zu wollen wenn
sie sich auf die beiden Paragraphen
konzentrieren die wirklich relevant sind
für Unternehmen nämlich direkte
Enteignung und Diskriminierung aufgrund
der Tatsache dass man ein ausländisches
Unternehmen ist mit den anderen beiden
Paragraphen die für viele klagen die
missbräunlich nicht angewendet wurden
die Grundlage waren ist in Zukunft
aufgrund unserer handelsagen das Schloss
und ja wir zeigen auch bei Sita was geht
wenn man sich einig ist was geht wenn
man einander zuhört wir haben es
geschafft gemeinsam mit der Europäischen
Kommission gemeinsam mit den
Mitgliedstaaten in der EU und gemeinsam
mit Kanada einen Vorschlag zu machen der
genau diese beiden missbrauchsanfälligen
und gefährlichsten Standards der
investitionsschutzverträge zu
reformieren einzuschränken klar zu
machen was in Zukunft alles nicht
gemeint ist und damit werden
missbräuchliche Klagen gegen Klimaschutz
und gegen Nachhaltigkeit in Zukunft so
Geschichte sein
und ein letzter Punkt weil ich ja auch
höre aus der Union dass sie von einem
neuen ttip Träumen ich frage mich immer
wieder ob sie eigentlich eine Politik
ohne jeglichen Bezug zu Realität machen
weil wo sind denn die USA über die sie
da reden wo sind denn die USA die bereit
wären ein solches Abkommen mit uns zu
verhandeln die existieren heute nicht
und die haben in der Vergangenheit auch
nicht existiert ttip ist gescheitert
schon unter Obama nicht aufgrund der
europäischen Umweltschutzbewegung ich
hätte mich gefreut wenn ich mich hier
hätte hinstellen können und sagen können
das war unser Erfolg tatsächlich war es
das Ergebnis von nicht überein zu
bringen den Interessen ökonomischer Art
zwischen der EU auf der einen Seite und
den USA auf der anderen Seite die
existieren heute in noch größere Maße
deswegen ist Teil einer realistischen
Handelspolitik dass man sich anschaut
was geht
dass man nicht träumt von gigantischen
monsterverträgen die sich gegenseitig
blockieren und die zurecht von den
Menschen in Frage gestellt werden
sondern dass man sagt lasst uns kleine
der Regeln finden lasst uns da
vorangehen wo es pragmatisch auch
sinnvoll ist lasst uns Gremien nutzen
wie den Trance Atlantic technology
Council wo wir eh schon miteinander
überstanden hat sprechen da kann man
realistisch Vorankommen lasst uns über
umweltschutzgüter sprechen lasst uns mal
ernst machen damit dass die EU und die
USA ein großer gemeinsamer
Wirtschaftsraum für Nachhaltigkeit sind
so wie es die amerikanische Regierung
auch verkündet hat da liegen Chancen der
immer in der Vergangenheit hängen bleibt
der kann die Zukunft nicht gestalten und
das ist vielleicht eine Lehre für Sie
als Union
Katharina dröge hat hier die Debatte
eröffnet und das seta-abkommen in der
jetzigen Form verteidigten momentan ist
es in der EU ja nur teilweise in Kraft
erst alle EU-Staaten müssen das Abkommen
ratifiziert haben bis es komplett in
Kraft tritt Julia Klöckner spricht jetzt
Klöckner spricht jetzt
Präsidentin Herr Bundesminister liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
unsere Wirtschaft muss unabhängiger
werden von außer autarkin der
Diversifizierung also eine breitere
Aufstellung will unabhängiger werden
will der muss natürlich
für Freihandel sein Freihandel mit
möglichst vielen strategischen Partnern
und Freunden in der Welt alleine schon
für die angestrebte Transformationen für
die sogenannte Energiewende sind wir auf
wichtige Rohstoffe von anderen
Kontinenten angewiesen wie Nickel wie
Kupfer oder auch Lithium aber viel zu
oft wird Freihandel viel zu oft in der
öffentlichen Debatte als etwas Negatives
dargestellt und angeheizt von den Grünen
sie haben in der vergangenen
Legislaturperiode alle
Globalisierungskritiker auf die Bäume
getrieben und jetzt erzählen sie das
Märchen der interpretationserklärung
dass sie das Ruder umgerissen hätten
weil die die auf den Bäumen sind jetzt
endlich wieder runterkommen müssen das
ist ihr Problem
aber kein anderes außer europäisches
Land steht uns in allen grundlegenden
Werten und der inneren Ordnung mehr als
Kanada und die Grünen haben eben nicht
nur eine Moral sie haben gleich zwei
davon
Bundesminister Harbeck sagte in Richtung
Kanada wir richten unsere Handelspolitik
konsequent am Klimaschutz aus und in
Richtung Kata sagt er nichts sondern
verneigt sich vom Emir und Richtung USA
wiederum lehnen sie einen neuen Anlauf
für Freihandelsabkommen ab ich frage Sie
liebe grüne wo ist ihr Kompass geblieben
in dieser Frage
und wenn wir die Standards und wenn wir
die Hürden an jeder Stelle so hoch
schrauben dann wird es ziemlich einsam
um uns wenn wir selbst mit den
demokratischen Staaten nicht mehr
schnell zusammenfinden dann haben wir
gar keine Partner mehr und noch vor der
Wahl ja wir beschließen es jetzt wird es
richtig goldig darüber her noch vor der
Wahl haben die Grünen erklärt Zita
keinesfalls zu ratifizieren und noch am
7 juli sagte der Kollege Andric von den
Grünen ich zitiere und deshalb werden
wir ceta nachverhandeln was haben sie
gemacht sie haben gar nichts gemacht sie
haben unrealistische Erwartungen
geschürt und nachverhandelt haben sie
gar nicht sondern heute werden wir
gemeinsam wir werden zustimmen einem
Gesetz zustimmen das wortgleich dem
unsregen ist dass wir bereits im März
eingebracht haben das heißt sie haben 11
mal unseren Gesetzentwurf
von der Tagesordnung genommen weil sie
eben nicht erkannt haben dass man mit
Partnern rasch einer Entscheidung trifft
sondern auf lange Zeit gespielt haben
wenn das bei Kanada schon so ist wie
soll das erst mit anderen Ländern werden
und deshalb diese inhaltetaktik ist ganz
interessant muss ich natürlich deshalb
sagen weil die FDP der Kollege
Kronenberg sagte noch am 7 juli im
Plenum die Kanadier sind Zitat irritiert
sie verstehen nicht warum Deutschland so
lange braucht das stimmt Liebe nein nein
nein nein auch goldig guck doch mal
jetzt jetzt kommt der
Fraktionsvorsitzende zeigt auf die Union
nennt sich doch 16 Jahre wissen wir das
schöne ist ja liebe FDP sie sagen was
anderes als sie tun es wurde immer
darauf verwiesen im Koalitionsvertrag
sobald das
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil da ist
dann wird entschieden wann war denn das
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil das war
im März und drei Tage nach diesem
Gerichtsurteil
haben wir diesen Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt
sie haben Monate gebraucht um jetzt
einen wortgleichen Gesetzentwurf
vorzulegen also liebe FDP peinlich ist
das Ganze dann schon
und dann diese Wundertüte
interpretationserklärung ich will mal
etwas wiedergeben aus der entsprechenden
Anhörung da wurde ja ihre sogenannte
interpretationserklärung zerpflückt
Professor Hindelang sagte wenn man nun
auf die Erklärung schaut wird hier
eigentlich gar nichts getan außer offene
Rechtsbegriffe mit weiteren offenen
Rechtsbegriffen zu erklären es ist eine
grüne Beruhigungspille und sogar der
SPD-Kollege sagte gestern im Ausschuss
ist ganz nicht wörtlich wiedergeben weil
das hier nicht erlaubt ist aber er sagte
sinngemäß diese interpretationserklärung
sei überflüssig dieser Meinung sind wir
auch das hat viel Zeit gekostet nun
werden wir diesen Gesetz dieses Gesetz
ratiifizieren bzw ein Gesetz haben dass
die Ratifizierung von zittern jetzt
voranbringt aber sehr geehrte Frau
Kollegin dröge Fraktionsvorsitzende der
Grünen ich werde dann auch mal die
Homepage etwas aktualisieren dort heißt
es heute bei ihnen noch sieter seit
politisch falsch und Zitat ich will
Zitat Bundestag verhindern ich hoffe das
haben sie nicht vor und in Zeiten
zunehmender Unsicherheiten will ich sehr
klar sagen das darf nicht
das Mexiko Australien wir brauchen
Partner die unsere Werte teilen und wir
brauchen eine Bundesregierung die
entscheidet und nicht hinhält herzlichen
Dank
die Kritik von Julia Klöckner
Frau Klöckner Minister was entgangen
glaube ich wenn sie mal bei Twitter
schauen dann hat sich da gestern Abend
die
vizepremierministerin von Kanada Frau
Freeland zu Wort gemeldet hat sich dafür
bedankt dass wir diesen Weg gehen und
hat ganz klar gesagt dass wir in diesen
Verhandlungen die wir innerhalb der
Europäischen Union geführt haben und die
wir mit Kanada geführt haben einen
großen Schritt gemacht haben indem wir
das angegangen sind weil wir verhandelt
haben weil wir Lösungen gefunden haben
und Sie gesucht haben und das ist das
was sie das ist das was sie nicht
geschafft haben in den letzten Jahren
sie haben eben keine Lösung gefunden und
das macht den Unterschied sie finden
keine Lösung wir finden eine Lösung es
gibt einen zweiten Punkt wir haben
mittlerweile und das zeigt auch wie
wichtig ist war Schritte nach vorne zu
machen wir haben mittlerweile viel
bessere Abkommen deswegen gehen wir bei
den allen alten Abkommen in Review
Prozesse um sie zu verbessern wir haben
aber mit Neuseeland einen neuen Standard
gesetzt in dem Sozialstandards drin sind
klimaschutzstandards sind und ja sind da
Adern hat sich gerade vor einigen Tagen
bei einer Pressekonferenz geäußert dass
das der Standard der Handelsabkommen der
Zukunft sein muss dass sie sich freut
mit Europa in Austausch zu treten genau
auf der Basis dieser Standards und da
merkt man eins sie haben es in der
vergangenen Legislaturperiode nicht
hingekriegt und sie sind noch immer
nicht auf Stand der Debatte das zeigt
sich in ganz vielen Fällen auch da sie
führen Debatte aus den letzten
Jahrzehnten diese Ampel bringt die
Handelspolitik jetzt ins 21 Jahrhundert
und dafür brauchte es offensichtlich
eine Zeit in der die CDU nicht Teil der
Bundesregierung ist und das ist gut so
sie haben das Wort ja Dankeschön man
merkt ja wie sie mental unter Druck sind
weil sie jetzt ihren Leuten da draußen
erklären müssen warum sie ceta womit sie
vor der Wahl noch geworben haben dass
sie es ablehnen werden weil es ja als
solches ganz schwierig ist dass sie dem
heute zustimmt ich verstehe das ja das
ist ja eine Rede an die eigenen Leute
von ihnen aber wir wollen ja auch im
Parlament auch ein bisschen seriös sein
und da geht es am Ende darum na ja aber
es geht ja am Ende darum sie haben
Zita Teile von Zita sind ja jetzt seit
Jahren schon in Kraft die EU-Kommission
hat Zahlen präsentiert wie sich das
Handelsvolumen des Handeln Miteinander
entwickelt hat sehr sehr positiv sehr
positiv und sie wollen uns jetzt alle
glauben machen dass eine
interpretationserklärung der Grünen
dieses Täter komplett neu aufgesetzt hat
also unter uns ich meine ich habe Sinn
für Humor
aber das ist eine Art von Humor der die
Leute echt ein bisschen für etwas im
Nebel hält ich bin jetzt freundlich weil
wir ja im Parlament sind und deshalb
freue ich mich mit ihnen die Debatten
der Zukunft zu führen weil ja jetzt
alles anders wird wie sie sagen und dann
ist Markus hoher ziemlich bald dran wir
legen ein Entwurf vor
zu einer Erklärung zur Aussprache erhält
der Kollege Carlo Kronberg
Carlo Kronberg aus der FDP-Fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen Klöckner sie haben mich
korrekt zitiert
sie wissen dass wir als Freie Demokraten
immer für eine schnelle Ratifizierung
von ceta eingetreten sind sie haben in
ihrer Rede ihrer Verwunderung Ausdruck
verliehen dass wir als Ampel vielleicht
lange gebraucht hätten ich darf daran
erinnern dass die Freien Demokraten vier
Monate gebraucht haben von der
konstituierenden Sitzung der WP 19 bis
zur Vorlage eines Gesetzesentwurfs der
ceta ratifizieren sollte vier Monate
haben wir gebraucht und seitdem also
vier Jahre warten wir darauf dass die
Union ratifiziert das haben sie nicht
getan sie hatten nicht die Kraft
jegliche politische Kraft rechtzeitig
dieses wichtige Freihandelsabkommen
abzuschließen und zum Erfolg zu führen
stattdessen haben sie sich auf das
Bundesverfassungsgericht zurückgezogen
und dieses
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil lag im
März vor ja und wir haben vor der
parlamentarischen
Sommerpause geeint
das welchen Weg wir einschlagen um die
Ratifizierung im Herbst und Kollege
Spahn der Herbst läuft noch
bis zum 21 Dezember haben wir Herbst wir
haben innerhalb von drei Monaten geeint
welchen Weg wir einschlagen um die
breite Zustimmung hier im Bundestag
sicherzustellen und das ist gelungen das
ist nicht langsam das ist schnell sehr
viel schneller als das was sie in der
Vergangenheit gemacht haben ich frage
mich überhaupt warum ceta seit Beginn
dieses Jahrhunderts die erste das erste
Freihandelsabkommen ist dass wir
überhaupt ratifizieren können also von
daher kein Vorwurf an die Freien
Demokraten kein Vorwurf an die Ampel
ich erkläre gleich auch mal unseren
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörern das eine war
eine Kurzintervention da ist es möglich
zu erwidern das war jetzt nach Paragraph
30 unserer Geschäftsordnung eine
Erklärung zur Aussprache da gibt es
jetzt gibt es keine Erwiderung und
ansonsten Kollegin Klöckner können wir
gerne gelegentlich mal über die
Geschäftsordnung miteinander reden aber
wir fahren jetzt in der Debatte fort und
das Wort hat die Kollegin Verena Huberts
für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin 2009
2016/2022 und heute ist es endlich so
weit denn wir ratifizieren ceta das EU
Freihandelsabkommen zwischen Kanada und
Europa und ich habe jetzt nicht umsonst
so viel über Zeit gesprochen das geht ja
auch nicht um Weltmeistertitel sondern
es waren Meilensteine die uns auf diesem
Weg zu diesem Vertrag begleitet haben
denn 2009 haben wir die Verhandlungen
gestartet 2016 waren sie fertig ein Jahr
später ist es vorläufig in Vertrag und
in Kraft getreten und heute
2022 ratifizieren wir im Deutschen
Bundestag damit ist es noch nicht
geschafft denn es fehlen noch elf
weitere Länder 11 weitere
Mitgliedstaaten aber wir sind
optimistisch jetzt wo wir vorangehen
dass auch weitere jetzt auch ganz
schnell folgen aber natürlich und das
wurde zu Recht gesagt ist das viel zu
lang und viel zu langsam in einer
globalisierten Welt die sich ganz
schnell dreht und die Frage ist ja warum
hat es so lange gedauert das war ja
jetzt nicht die Gemütlichkeit sondern
wir haben auf ein
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil gewartet
es sind auch 1300 Seiten wer sich mal
damit intensiv beschäftigt der weiß dass
es da um mehr geht als um Zölle es geht
nämlich auch jetzt schon um
Nachhaltigkeit um soziale Standards aber
wir haben auch noch mal Bedenken
ausgeräumt und die sind eben sehr
relevant nämlich dass diese
Schiedsgerichte wo sich einfach Konzerne
mit Geld den Richter aussuchen dass wir
die hinter uns lassen und wirklich jetzt
auch mal internationale bilaterale
multilaterale öffentliche Gerichtshilfe
schaffen denn da gehört das Recht auch
hin auch im internationalen Handel liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ja in dieser Welt reicht es nicht
nur mit kanadaverträge zu schließen
natürlich müssen wir doch gerade
diversifizieren wir brauchen mehr
Partner anstatt weniger wir müssen dazu
koppeln wir müssen aber auch ganz mit
Bedacht auf Verbindungen gucken wo wir
uns in der Vergangenheit auch in
Abhängigkeiten begeben haben also
entkoppeln da wo es nötig ist und wir
gehen da strategisch vor wir haben jetzt
eine Agenda geschrieben wo wir uns auch
noch mal jetzt ganz genau mit Mexiko mit
Australien Neuseeland chilien Chile
Brasilien wo sich auch neue Fenster
öffnen nach einer gewonnenen Wahl
beschäftigen werden und vor allen Dingen
lassen wir
veraltete Verträge zurück nämlich die wo
wir sagen da ist gar keine Reform mehr
möglich zum Beispiel bei der
energiekater und ja das tun wir nicht
losgelöst sondern eben auch handeln und
agierend eingebettet in ein Konzern
Gesamtkonzept und genau das tut diese
Ampel Regierung
und ja wir müssen uns auch mal ehrlich
machen zu dieser Welt gehört auch dass
nicht jeder eins zu eins genau unsere
Werte verteilen können aber ich bin
davon überzeugt kein Abkommen ist auch
keine Lösung wenn es darum geht unseren
Wohlstand und auch für unsere Werte in
dieser Welt einzustehen
und natürlich haben wir auch einen Plan
nach vorne denn dort drüben haben wir
den Inflation reduction Acts da müssen
wir auch eine europäische Antwort finden
da bin ich der optimistisch dass wir
diese auch schnell finden werden und
natürlich müssen wir offen bleiben für
Gespräche für Kooperation mit allen
Partnern die unsere Werte teilen und wir
fangen heute damit an mit einer neuen
Generation an Handelsverträgen mit mehr
Handel und vor allen Dingen mit einer
sehr sehr wichtigen Brücke über den
Atlantik zu unseren Freundinnen und
Freundinnen nach Kanada und daher werde
ich gleich um ihre Zustimmung zu diesem
wichtigen Gesetz vielen Dank
nächster Redner in der Debatte ist nun
Bernd Schattner er sitzt für die
afd-fraktion im Ausschuss für Ernährung
und Landwirtschaft
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
200.000 Menschen demonstrierten im
September 2016 in ganz Deutschland gegen
ceta und ttip vorne weg damals auch die
heutige grüne Außenministerin Annalena
bärburg sie und ihre Mitstreiter
brachten Angelika Merkel und ihre
damaligen Vizekanzler und
Wirtschaftsminister Sigmar Gabriel von
der SPD dazu das 2017 von der
EU-Kommission unterzeichnete Abkommen im
Bundestag über die gesamte Legislatur
nicht zu ratifizieren zu heftig schien
damals der gesellschaftliche Gegenwind
das nun ausgerechnet die Ampel Mehrheit
mit Frau beerburg als Außenministerin
vollzieht ist ein bemerkenswerter
Vorgang die Tatsache dass die
Verhandlungen zwischen Kanada und der EU
7 Jahre und jetzt die Ratifizierung
durch die Bundesregierung weitere sechs
Jahre also insgesamt 13 Jahre angedauert
hat zeigt dass dieses Abkommen nicht nur
Fürsprecher hat sondern nach wie vor
höchst umstritten ist
bisher kann man von den Zahlen her
festhalten das Kanada 2021 laut
un-comtrade Waren im Wert von 488,5
Milliarden US-Dollar importierte davon
standen lediglich 3,1% aus Deutschland
die Start ist zur Folge lag das Land auf
Rang 27 der wichtigsten deutschen
Absatzmärkte Kanada exportierte hingegen
2021 Waren im Wert von 500,9 Milliarden
US-Dollar und ein Prozent davon ging
nach Deutschland laut ist datisla Kanada
damit auf Rang 36 der wichtigsten
deutschen Bezugsmärkte also das kann es
nicht sein was den Handel mit dem
zweitgrößten Flächenland der Erde zu
attraktiv macht
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren mit
den eben hervorgetragenen Zahlen Daten
und Fakten habe ich jedoch nur den
Ist-Zustand geschrieben die Frage ist
jedoch wie lange wird dieser noch
Bestand haben denn der Inhalt des
aktuellen Abkommens muss nicht auch für
die Zukunft gelten fakt ist dass mit der
Verabschiedung dieses Abkommens die
gemeinsamen Ausschüsse ermächtigt werden
das Abkommen nachträglich auch noch zu
verändern und zwar man höhere und staune
ohne einer weiteren Befassung des
Bundestages und einer solchen Aushebung
des Parlaments werden wir von der AFD
definitiv nicht zustimmen können
warum will die Bundesregierung trotz
allem auf Teufel komm raus dieses
Abkommen
könnte es vielleicht daran liegen dass
Kanada mit fast 200 Milliarden
Kubikmetern Erdgasproduktion jährlich
die fünftgrößte Menge weltweit fördert
demnach muss man doch sehr stark
annehmen dass das ceta-abkommen nur die
verschleier die Überschrift ist für ein
zukünftiges Gas und ölabkommen zwischen
Deutschland und Kanada aber wie passt
diese Phase mit der ach so
umweltfreundlichen rückschrittskoalition
eigentlich zusammen wie wir meinen gar
nicht denn während und 71% des Gases in
Kanada durch Fracking gefördert wird ist
dies in Deutschland seit 2017 verboten
und das aus guten Grund hier zeigt sich
einmal mehr die Doppelmoral der links
grünen ruinösen Politik allein schon der
Transport von Gas bzw Öl von Kanada nach
Deutschland wäre um ein Vielfaches
teurer als wenn wir die diplomatischen
Verhandlungen mit Russland suchen und
damit weiterhin die Energie und
Versorgungssicherheit der Deutschen
bevölkerungssichern würden und wenn ich
mir jetzt zum Schluss noch den Antrag
der Union anziehe dann habe ich da den
ganz bösen Verdacht dass das Ziel der
Union eigentlich nur die Zerstörung der
deutschen Landwirtschaft sein kann nicht
anders ist es nämlich zu erklären dass
die ehemalige selbstlernende bauernparte
dass mir Kulturabkommen fordert und
damit Millionen Tonnen an
südamerikanischen Billigfleisch nach
Deutschland importieren will und damit
die Landwirte auf dem Altar des
freihandelsopfert und dazu können wir
als AFD nur sagen mit uns wird auch
dieses Abkommen so nicht zu machen sein
vielen Dank
das Wort hat der Kollege Christian dürr
für die FDP-Fraktion Christian
der Liberalen im Deutschen Bundestag
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen Deutschland
ist die viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der
Welt wir sind eine Exportnation und wir
haben eine handelstradition ich denke an
die Hansestädte da steht ja das Wort
Freihandel sozusagen historisch schon im
Namen wir sind ein Land was immer auf
Freihandel ausgerichtet war und als
Demokratie in Europa wollen wir mehr
Freihandel mit den Demokratien der Welt
denn wir befinden uns in einem
systemwettbewerb und wir haben
festgestellt angesichts der furchtbaren
geopolitischen Krise die wir zurzeit
erleben dass Abhängigkeiten bestehen die
uns auch gefährlich geworden sind die
teilweise unseren Wohlstand bedrohen
insbesondere was energieabhängigkeiten
betrifft aber natürlich auch systemische
Abhängigkeiten wenn ich beispielsweise
an die Volksrepublik China denke und
deswegen muss die Antwort sein dass wir
mehr Freihandelsabkommen mit den
Demokratien der Welt haben wollen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist das
Ziel dieser Koalition um das am Anfang
deutlich zu sagen und deswegen werden
wir heute das freiensabkommen ceta durch
den Deutschen Bundestag bringen und hier
ratifizieren mit dieser modernen
handelsagenda setzen wir ein wichtiges
Zeichen und daher die Kollegin Klöckner
sehr auf die Vergangenheit rekorierte
und ihr
unbewusst offensichtlich ist das über
viele Jahre ceta während der
Regierungszeit der Union eben nicht
ratifiziert worden ist will ich noch mal
eins in Erinnerung rufen wir schaffen
jetzt nach nur einem Jahr
Regierungsverantwortung ein erstes
wichtiges großes verhandelsabkommen was
war denn zur Zeit der unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung
sie haben während ihrer gesamten
Regierungszeit ein einziges
vereinsabkommen auf den Weg gebracht und
das war mit Südkorea es war übrigens
erfolgreich am Ende des Tages der
Anstieg des Handelsvolumen von fast von
über 70 Prozent im Vergleich zum Jahr
2011 spricht an der Stelle Bände das
Handelsabkommen mit Südkorea ist im Jahr
2011 geschlossen worden als sie mit den
Freien Demokraten regiert haben ist
nicht doch offensichtlich vor allem auch
an der Union das ist in den vergangenen
Jahren nicht geklappt hat mit besserer
Handelspolitik und einer neuen
handelsagenter für Deutschland nach
wenigen Monaten bringen wir bereits
Zehnter auf den Weg und wir machen an
der Stelle nicht Halt sondern wir wollen
die Handelsabkommen mit Chile und Mexiko
zum Abschluss bringen und
schnellstmöglich auch dass
merkurabkommen mit Südamerika meine
Damen und Herren und
und wir wollen einen Schritt weitergehen
die handelsagenda die wir heute
mehrheitlich im Deutschen Bundestag
beschließen und ich bin sehr gespannt
wie sie unseren Entschließungsantrag am
Ende nicht nur finden sondern wie sie
dazu votieren wir haben uns als
Ampelkoalition fest vorgenommen einen
neuen Anlauf zu nehmen mit einem
Freihandelsabkommen mit den Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika einer westlichen
Demokratie ein transatlantisches Bündnis
stärken wir damit Herr Kollege Spahn das
ist die Position dieser Koalition wir
wollen mit den Demokratien der
Welthandel Treiben im gegenseitigen und
beiderseitigen Interesse liebe Kollegen
die Vereinigten Staaten
investieren in der Europäischen Union
viermal so viel wie in ganz Asien die
Europäische Union zehnmal so viel in den
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika im
Vergleich mit China und Indien zusammen
die transatischen Beziehung sind ein
Schlüssel in der globalen Wirtschaft und
wir werden damit auch unsere
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit auf neue Füße
stellen meine Damen und Herren wenn wir
uns die Frage stellen was sind die Jobs
von morgen müssen wir gleichzeitig die
Frage stellen wo diese Jobs entstehen
sie entstehen dort wo es attraktive
Investitionsbedingungen geht sie
entstehen dort wo es nur Haut
Technologie und wissen gibt dass
exportiert werden kann und sie entstehen
dort wo die attraktivsten Bedingungen
für Fachkräfte aller Art bestehen meine
Damen und Herren wir werden hier
weitermachen ceta ist ein erster
wichtiger großer Schritt der über viele
Jahre nicht funktioniert hat mit der
alten Regierung ceta ist ein erster
Schritt meine Damen und Herren aber wir
machen an dieser Stelle nicht halt wenn
wir es schaffen
die Freihandelsabkommen mit den
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika auf dem
Weg zu bringen dann vereinen wir den
Welthandel ein Drittel des Welthandels
wird dann liberalisiert sein und 60
Prozent des
weltbruttoinlandsprodukts werden wir in
einer gemeinsamen Wirtschaftszone haben
das Ziel und die Antwort auf den
systemwettbewerb den wir den derzeit
global erlebt lautet wir brauchen mehr
Freihandel mit den Demokratien der Welt
liebe Kolleginnen und das bringt die
Ampelkoalition nach vorne der Union ist
das in allen Jahren nicht gelungen und
das in aller Deutlichkeit zu sagen
7 700.000 Jobs sind durch das
vorläufigen krafttreten von ceta bereits
in der Europäischen Union entstanden
bereits jetzt ist das ein Erfolgsmodell
und das zeigt doch eines lassen Sie uns
auf diesem Weg weitergehen wir haben
viele kommen ich habe die Uhr angehalten
entschuldigung kein Problem
der Kollege Kuban wünscht eine Frage
oder merkung hier ich freue mich sehr
darüber ja
sie haben ja eben gerade Herr Kollege
dürr so sehr für ein Freihandelsabkommen
mit den USA plädiert und wir haben ja
eben gerade auch die Rede von Frau dröge
gehört zu der Aussage wo sie Aussage
getroffen hat dass es kein
freiheitsabkommen mit den USA braucht
weiß die das schon diese das was sie da
gerade erzählt haben
Frau Kollegin Tröger hat richtigerweise
von hier vorne auf das gescheiterte
Franz am Computer rekoriert und die
Union war ja derzeit auch in der
Bundesregierung als das am Ende des
Tages gescheitert ist was ich nicht was
ich in der Sache bedauere aber sehr gut
den Anlass verstehe weil damals die
Dinge schlecht ausgehandelt waren ich
will ihnen das ganz klar sagen Herr
Kollege Kuban sie reden immer
immer auch jetzt in der Opposition aber
sie machen nicht in der letzten
haushaltswoche ich will das hier mal
erwähnen ist ganz viel von der Union an
rhetore gekommen aber nichts an Handeln
in der Vergangenheit ist ganz viel an
Rhetorik gekommen beim Thema
Freihandelsabkommen und mehr
Handelsabkommen aber es ist nicht
durchgebracht worden der Unterschied ist
doch in Wahrheit dass wir machen und
nicht nur schnacken wir sind beide
Niedersachsen das ist der Unterschied an
dieser Stelle liebe Kollegen Kollegen
und deswegen
und deswegen kann man hier lange
philosophieren man kann lange versuchen
politisch zu taktieren ich empfehle der
Opposition der größten
Oppositionsparteien im Deutschen
Bundestag diesen Weg einer neuen
handelsagengender die sich diese
Regierungsmehrheit vorgeschrieben hat
diesen Weg mit uns gemeinsam zu gehen
damit wir den wirtschaftlichen Erfolg
auch Deutschlands in Zukunft
gewährleisten nicht danke Ihnen
Christian dürr war das der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der FDP-Fraktion
ein Klöckner
eine Erklärung zur Aussprache ist ja
dann möglich wenn man falsch
wiedergegeben worden ist haben wir
gerade eben gelernt und deshalb nehmen
wir das gerne in Anspruch der Kollege
dürr hat eben gesagt dass die
Unionsfraktion zitter in der vergangenen
Legislatur immer blockiert hätte das ist
falsch denn eines ist erstens sehr klar
ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern dass
wir die absolute Mehrheit gehabt hätten
als cdu/csu zweitens war ist die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion die gegen zittern
mit folgenden Gründen gestimmt hat so
lange ist kein
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil solange es das
nicht gibt würde man nicht zustimmen und
dann sehr geehrter Herr Kollege dürr
haben sie selbst selbst sie haben als
FDP einem Koalitionsvertrag zugestimmt
in dem stand erst dann wenn das
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil vorliegt dann
werden sie sich zitter annehmen und
insofern muss ich sagen das hätte dann
im März passieren können und jetzt haben
wir Dezember
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Petra Power
hat es schon angekündigt das wird heute
bis 3 Uhr nachts hier so weitergehen
dass auch diejenigen die uns heute
zuhören und Zuschauen die Geschichte
dieses Tagesordnungspunktes der heute zu
einer entsprechenden Abstimmung kommen
wird auch nachvollziehen können weil das
begleitet uns ja in der Tat über mehrere
Legislaturperioden ich gehe jetzt davon
aus dass die Möglichkeiten der
Geschäftsordnung einen klar sind aber
wir auch alle das Ziel haben tatsächlich
am Ende dieser Debatte abzustimmen und
auch unsere weitere anspruchsvolle
Tagesordnung des heutigen Tages noch zu
bearbeiten deshalb fahren wir jetzt fort
in der Debatte das Wort hat der Kollege
Bernd rixinger für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
das Freihandelsabkommen ceta endgültig
zu ratifizieren ist ein großer Fehler
hunderttausende haben gegen ceta
demonstriert Umweltverbände
Gewerkschaften und Sozialverbände waren
vor den Folgen ihre Stimmen bleiben ein
weiteres Mal von dieser Regierung
ungehört um was geht es 2017 ist ceta
das Handelsabkommen zwischen der EU und
Kanada zu großen Teilen in Kraft
getreten es wurde von der großen
Koalition nicht vollständig ratifiziert
das geschieht nun ausgerechnet unter der
Führung eines grünen
Wirtschaftsministers ich erinnere mich
gut daran an die große Demonstration in
Berlin 2016 mit
2.250.000 Teilnehmerinnen auf der
Rednerbühne stand neben mir Anton
Hofreiter der laut und deutlich dazu
aufrief ceta zu stoppen übrigens hat er
recht gehabt damals aber heute gelten ja
andere Kriterien damals gab es den
konsen dass wir eine andere Form des
Welthandels wollen
ein regierungsjahr später soll mit Ihrer
Zustimmung ceta ratifiziert werden und
das obwohl sie genau wissen dass der
ceta Investitionsschutz der nun
vollständig wirksam werden soll
Demokratie Klima und Sozialstandards
gefährden wird und machen Sie sich doch
nichts vor ihre
interpretationserklärung mit der sie
sich ceta schönreden ist rechtlich
nichts wert am rechtlichen Rahmen von
ceta den insbesondere die Grünen zu
recht massiv kritisiert haben hat sich
nichts aber auch gar nichts geändert
mit der endgültigen Ratifizierung machen
sie den Weg frei für weitere
Sonderrechte für Konzerne gegen Gesetze
die hier demokratisch zum Beispiel für
höhere soziale Standards oder für Klima
und Umweltschutz beschlossen werden kann
so von international agierenden
Konzernen vor einer
sondergerichtsbarkeit also einer auf
Konzerninteressen abgestimmten
Paralleljustiz geklagt werden der
Energiekonzern unüber verklagt gerade
den niederländischen Staat vor einem
Schiedsgericht der Konzern fordert knapp
eine Milliarde Euro weil in den
Niederlanden die Regierung bis 2030 aus
der Kohle aussteigen will
natürlich ich sage ja nur dass es diese
Klagen gibt und die werden weiterhin
möglich sein weiterhin gibt es
Sondergerichte ich weiß gar nicht wie
sie darauf kommen dass diese Klagen
nicht mehr möglich sein sollen laut
Greenpeace würden mindestens 360
kanadische Unternehmen durch ceta
sonderklagerechtig gegen Deutschland
bekommen dazu kommen noch US-Konzerne
über ihre kanadischen
Tochtergesellschaften schon jetzt ist
klar dass sie offensichtlich den Weg des
ungebremsten Freihandels weitergehen
wollen auch das Abkommen mit den USA
wird von ihnen wieder aus der
Mottenkiste hervorgeholt haben wir ja
gerade gehört die radie radifizierung
vom Markus zur Abkommen steht kurz bevor
die Grünen haben offensichtlich ihren
Widerstand gegen den neoliberalen
Freihandel vollends aufgegeben
wir als LINKE lehnen derartige Abkommen
weiterhin konsequent ab
wir stehen für eine Neuausrichtung der
EU Handelspolitik
Arbeitnehmer Klima und Verbraucherschutz
müssen Vorfahrt haben
einen weiteren Ausverkauf sowie eine auf
Konzerninteressen zugeschnittene
Paralleljustiz darf es nicht geben
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
den Wirtschaftsminister hatten wir schon
im Bild er wird allerdings erst mal
nicht sprechen sondern seine
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin beim
Bundesminister für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz das ist Franziska Brandner
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren heute ist ein
besonderer Tag
wir
wenden uns der Welt zu und gleichzeitig
stärken wir den Klimaschutz
und Frau Klöckner sie haben mir gesagt
wir hätten keinen Kompass und während zu
langsam
nach 16 Jahren Merkel haben wir
Abhängigkeiten in nicht
vorstellbarer Höhe von Putin und chising
Ping das ist das Ergebnis ihrer Politik
die wir jetzt versuchen rückgängig zu
machen
und zweitens haben sie 16 Jahre lang
Handel gegen Klimaschutz ausgespielt sie
haben es intellektuell und fachlich
nicht geschafft Handel und Klimaschutz
zusammenzubringen und haben deswegen
unser ganzes Land gespalten
und wenn wir es heute schaffen dann ist
es weil die Ampel die Kraft hat dass und
nicht nur zu denken sondern umzusetzen
und wir wollen und wir müssen
diversifizieren wir wollen unsere
Abhängigkeiten reduzieren
Partnerschaften eingehen und zwar nicht
von oben herab sondern auf Augenhöhe wir
wollen das Angebot machen weltweit mit
uns die Grünen
Wertschöpfungsketten der Zukunft
aufzubauen das ist eine große Aufgabe
aber eine die es sich lohnt anzugehen
mit den Partnerländern wie Ziele wie
Mexiko wie bei Merkur aber ebenso dass
wir am Ende die Grünen
Wertschöpfungsketten stärken und das
Klima schützen
und Herr rexinger
sie haben hier gerade uniper
angesprochen und die Niederlande erstens
durch die Übernahme wird genau diese
Klage ja zurückgezogen und zweitens die
Grundlage auf der diese Klage passiert
ist ja nicht ceta sondern der
energiekatervertrag und aus dem Dreh
sind wir ja jetzt ausgetreten also
deswegen Herr Ritzinger vielleicht
sollten Sie das in der Sekunde mal
erwähnen dass wir genau deswegen ja aus
dem energiekatervertrag Aussteigen und
Herr Ritzinger sie können hier nicht
sagen die Entscheidung des Gemeinsamen
Ausschusses ist nichts wert nicht
rechtlich bildlich und in der gleichen
Rede sagen aufgrund dieses Gemeinsamen
Ausschusses endet die Demokratie hier
der parlamentarischen hier Kontrolle
also müssen sich schon entscheiden
entweder hat diese Ausschuss nichts zu
sagen oder es ist Ende der Demokratie ja
aber in einer Rede Gleiches zu behaupten
das ist schon echt sehr frech und es ist
eben genauso das ist nicht das Ende der
Demokratie ist aber eben rechtlich
bildlich für die Schiedsgerichte und
deswegen einen Unterschied macht einen
richtigen und wichtigen den wir
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
Partnerinnen und Partnern gehen und auch
entsprechend für die anderen Verträge
noch präzisieren und voranbringen werden
das ist gut für unsere Wirtschaft für
unseren Wohlstand und für das Klima bei
uns und weltweit ich danke für die
Zusammenarbeit mit den Koalitionen das
war eine große Freude herzlichen Dank
für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat nun jens-
und im Gegensatz zu Twitter Kanada hat
bis jetzt der interpretationserklärung
noch nicht zugestimmt sie werden beim
ceta das rechtlich nichts anderes ist
als das was seit sechs Jahren vorliegt
heute zuständig es ist gut dass Sie
zustimmen aber reden sie sich nicht was
anderes ein in der Frage über dem was
wir hier heute zur Abstimmung haben
und das Entscheidende ist ja dass ceta
das Abkommen mit Kanada erst der Anfang
und nicht der Endpunkt der
Handelspolitik ist und der Kollege dürr
ich weiß nicht ob sie der Frau Kollegin
dröge zugehört haben sie hat gesagt ein
Handelsabkommen Freihandel mit den USA
wäre irreal wer davon träume der wäre in
einer falschen Welt insofern habe ich
den Eindruck wenn Sie das angehen wollen
was Sie gesagt haben Herr Kollege dürr
Freihandel mit den USA mehr Kultur all
die anderen Länder die sie aufgezählt
haben uns haben Sie bei einer solchen
Handelspolitik zu jeder Zeit an der
Seite die Frage ist auch nach dem was
wir hier so in die Gesichter gesehen
haben haben Sie eigentlich eine
gemeinsame Position in der Koalition zu
der Frage wie diese Handelspolitik
aussehen soll
ganz am Anfang einer Handelsstrategie
übrigens auch einer china-strategie muss
eine deutschlandstrategie stehen denn
wir sind als Partner für andere nur
attraktiv und übrigens haben wir auch
nur ein Hebel um bestimmte Dinge
umzusetzen wenn wir selbst
wirtschaftlich stark sind deswegen
gehört dazu die Frage Industriestandort
zu bleiben Technologie Führer zu sein in
vielen Bereichen und am Ende eben eine
attraktiver Partner der die Resilienz
stärkt indem er möglichst viele
Handelsverträge mit unterschiedlichen
Partnern schließt und nicht zu abhängig
von einzelnen zu sein und der die eigene
Relevanz stärkt indem er selbst nämlich
eben als Partner wirtschaftlich stark
ist deswegen muss jeder Startpunkt einer
Handels auch einer china-strategie eine
deutschlandstrategie sein zu dieser
Strategie gehört es auch realpolitisch
pragmatisch zu sein
Handelsverträge nicht zu überfrachten
mit allen möglichen Themen wie schnell
man sich sonst in seinem eigenen
moralgarten verlieren kann haben wir ja
in den letzten zwei Wochen gesehen
zuerst ein Knicks vor dem Emir 6 Wochen
später heißt es man würde selber doch
mit der one love-binde auf dem Spielfeld
auflaufen nur um dann eine Woche später
einen 15-jahresvertrag mit Qatar super
zu finden weniger konsequent kann Werte
gebundene Außenpolitik sogenannte nicht
sein das haben wir in den letzten Wochen
gesehen
die Lehre daraus ist doch dass wir als
Exportnation aufpassen müssen dass wir
nicht unsere gesamte Außen- und
Handelspolitik moralisieren das sollten
wir für künftige Handelsverträge und für
die Debatten in der Handelspolitik
beachten gewisse Standards ja natürlich
auch Klima und arbeitsschutzstandards
aber versuchen Sie nicht jeden
Handelsvertrag zum Instrument ihrer
Moral zu machen und das haben wir doch
gerade wieder gehört Frau Kollegin
Brandner wenn es darum geht
Partnerschaft auf Augenhöhe zu machen
dann sollte man tatsächlich eben mit
diesen Ländern auch auf tatsächlicher
Augenhöhe verhandeln wenn andere Aspekte
mit hineinkommen dass das geht meistens
schief siehe Katar im Mittelpunkt von
Handelspolitik sollte Handel stehen und
das sollte auch im Mittelpunkt von
Handelsverträgen stehen
und damit komme ich zurück zum Anfang
Relevanz und Resilienz entsprechend
entspringen aus eigener Stärke jeder
Handelsstrategie braucht vorneweg eine
deutschlandstrategie denn nur dann haben
wir überhaupt den Hebel auch gewisse
Werte und Rechtsvorstellungen als
attraktiver Partner in entsprechenden
Verträgen umzusetzen in diesem Kontext
ist ceta das heutige Abkommen dass wir
ratifizieren ein erster ein wichtiger
wenn auch jetzt ein sehr spät gegangener
Schritt nicht mehr aber auch nicht
weniger und deswegen werden wir
zustimmen
das Wort hat der Kollege Markus Töns für
die SPD-Fraktion
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen frau
Präsidentin
liebe Zuhörerinnen
Lob loswerden nämlich für die
Präsidentin weil sie versucht hat auch
sie auf der Tribüne ein bisschen
mitzunehmen bei dieser Debatte manch
einem Kollegen hier fällt es auch schwer
die Fakten beieinander zu halten und
vielleicht ist es in dem Zusammenhang
dann auch schwer zu verstehen worüber
wir eigentlich debattieren ich will da
mal auf den Punkt kommen um das mal zu
erklären mach mal einen kleinen
Faktencheck
Handelspolitik liegt einzig und allein
in der Kompetenz der Europäischen Union
einzig und allein in der Kompetenz und
der Europäischen Union und sie
verhandelt das auch wir geben als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in der
Handelspolitik der Kommission in ein
Mandat im Europäischen Rat einstimmig 27
und das ist passiert was haben wir jetzt
wir reden über Kita und nicht über
andere Handelsverträge wir reden aber
darüber dass wir eine moderne
Handelspolitik wollen das ist unser
Punkt und Zita ist abgeschlossen worden
unter anderem
ist es abgeschlossen worden weil Sigmar
Gabriel und Sozialdemokratinnen und
Sozialdemokraten in Europa ist geschafft
haben einen der modernsten
Investitionsschutz Kapitel zu
formulieren und das macht es erst
zustimmungsfähig Herr Ritzinger und ich
will das an der Stelle noch mal sagen
seit 2017 übrigens in der vorläufigen
Anwendung weil es dort auch ein eine
Ratifizierung im Europäischen Rat
gegeben hat und im Europaparlament und
dann will ich auch noch mal was dazu
sagen was das heißt das ist übrigens
völkerrechtlich vollkommen normal selbst
der Westfälische Friede wurde vorläufig
angewendet und das ja auch schon ein
paar Jahre her ich will das nun mal noch
fahren an der Stelle erklären also liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben einen
investitionsgerichtshof wird geschaffen
in zittern dass er ein richtiges Gericht
im Sinne des Völkerrechts mit richtigem
richterninnen und Richtern mit der
nötigen Befähigung zum Richteramt es
wird transparent verhandelt es gibt die
Möglichkeit zur Weiterentwicklung weil
weil es nämlich so angelegt ist dass die
kommen die Kommission in Brüssel
mittlerweile auch mit 40 Staaten darüber
verhandelt ihn zu einem multilateralen
investitionsgerichtshof zu entscheiden
das ist wirklich wichtig ja ich bin auch
dass es durchaus
richtig in ich bin auch der Meinung dass
wir nicht unbedingt eine
interpretationserklärung gebraucht
hätten aber ich bin der Meinung dass man
wenn wir mit der
interpretationserklärung wenn wir mit
der Interpretation hören sie gut zu Frau
Klöckner können Sie noch was lernen wenn
sie mit der interpretationserklärung es
hinbekommen zu erklären dass die Dinge
die kritisch gesehen wurden bei den
Demonstrationen im Vertrag enthalten
sind dass sie
den Standards entsprechend die wir als
Werte auch tragen dann ist diese
interpretationserklärung auch richtig
und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich will
dann auch noch mal mit weil das ja auch
mal gerne in dem Zusammenhang genannt
wird mit ein paar Mythen aufräumen die
in diesem Zusammenhang unterwegs sind
also es wird immer behauptet dass white
to regulate also dass wir als Bundestag
oder die europäisch das Europäische
Parlament nicht mehr weiter entscheiden
können keine Gesetze erlassen können
weil ja Unternehmen uns verklagen können
das ist definitiv falsch das weite
regulate wie es heißt ist im Vertrag ja
befindet sich im Vertrag und ist dort
auch enthalten
angebliches sonderklagerecht für
Unternehmen da ist noch wirklich der
größte Blödsinn richte das mal so sagen
darf das gibt's nicht wenn wir kein
Investitionsschutz machen wie wir ihn
jetzt verhandeln dann fallen wir auch
WTO-Recht zurück ich will das noch mal
erklären das heißt dann gibt es die
sonderklagerecht das gibt schon längst
zu wissen wo die dann Klagen vor
intransparenten Schiedsgerichten das
passiert wenn Sie das Ablehnen sie
sollten mal darüber nachdenken ob sie
nicht einen modernen Investitionsschutz
zustimmen und der Schutz der
Daseinsvorsorge der wird ja auch häufig
vorangesprochen der ist übrigens im
Vertrag von Lissabon und im Grundgesetz
geschützt und kann durch keinen Vertrag
regelt werden und das will ich zum
Abschluss noch mal etwas Wichtiges sagen
was übrigens grundsätzlich wichtig ist
für diesen Vertrag und für zukünftige
vertrage das ist nämlich die Rolle und
die Beteiligung des Deutschen
Bundestages es gibt Berichtspflichten
der Bundesregierung das haben wir
übrigens
Entschließungsantrag übrigens noch mal
deutlich formuliert die sind geregelt im
oezbwg das kennen Sie auch manch einer
wird das die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
müssten das eigentlich kennen sie werden
das vielleicht nicht unbedingt kennen
die zuhören oder im AEUV und es ist im
Artikel 23 des Grundgesetzes geregelt
dieser Artikel gibt uns alle
Mitwirkungsmöglichkeiten die wir
brauchen als Bundestag und damit werden
wir unserer Verpflichtung nachkommen
und
ganz zum Schluss noch mal etwas es ist
die Verpflichtung zur Einstimmigkeit in
die nichtenausschuss in den Ausschüssen
dieses Vertrages festgelegt ich will das
an dieser Stelle zum Abschluss dann auch
noch mal sagen ich hätte mir gewünscht
dass sie Union und übrigens auch
zustimmen würde einen Unterausschuss zu
bilden damit kämen wir unserer
Verpflichtung gegenüber dem
Verfassungsgericht nach das ist so ja
und wir können das gerne noch
miteinander fahren sie können ja noch
mal drüber nachdenken an der stelle ich
kann nur sagen ist ein guter Tag für
dieses Parlament es ist ein guter Tag
für diesen Vertrag ich freue mich darauf
dass wir gleich Zita abschließen werden
ratifizieren Glückauf
Markus Töns war das für die SPD-Fraktion
wir haben allerdings noch einige Redner
vor uns die sich hier auch noch zu
diesem Abkommen äußern werden unter
anderem malte Kaufmann für die
afd-fraktion Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren auch wir als AFD sehen natürlich
dass ein funktionierender
internationaler Handel für Deutschland
notwendig und wohlstandsfördernd ist
jedenfalls dann wenn man ihn richtig
organisiert
und genau nur dann und genau hier liegen
eben bei ceta die Bedenken unserer
Bürgerpartei Bedenken die von der
Regierungskoalition nicht ausgeräumt
werden konnten mein Kollege Bernd
Schattner hat in seiner Rede bereits
wichtige Punkte dargelegt
hinweisen möchte ich noch einmal auf die
unseres Erachtens nicht
zufriedenstellend geklärte Frage welche
Befugnisse der gemeinsame Ausschuss der
ceta-mitgliedsstaaten eigentlich haben
wird
mittlerweile sogar von einer
Fortentwicklung des Abkommens durch
diesen Ausschuss die Rede das aber ist
die Aufgabe der nationalen Parlamente
eine Aushöhlung des parlamentsvorbehalts
wäre ein Verstoß gegen ein zentrales
demokratisches Prinzip
auch die Kompetenzen dieses Ausschusses
beim strittigen Thema investitions-
genau dieses Thema wird uns aber
garantiert auf die Füße fallen denn
dieser Investitionsschutz hat das
Potenzial für Deutschland sehr teuer zu
werden auch wenn dies seitens der Ampel
stets klein geredet wird auch heute
wieder übrigens ist das genau das
gleiche Muster wie auf anderen
Politikfeldern wo man unsere Bedenken
zunächst einfach so wegwischt und dann
später feststellt dass wir mit unseren
Analysen exakt Recht hatten Stichwort
Migrationspolitik Energiewende
Euro-Rettung und jetzt auch corona-
zurück zu ceta und den möglicherweise
sehr teuren
die kommen nämlich dann auf uns als
Steuerzahler zu wenn Deutschland in
intransparenten Schiedsgerichtsverfahren
zu hohen Entschädigungszahlungen für
ausländische Investoren verurteilt wird
Bedenken rund um diesen
Investitionsschutz scheint man bei der
Bundesregierung nicht wirklich ernst zu
nehmen die wurden auch nicht ausgeräumt
weder im Ausschuss noch bei unserer
Anhörung kürzlich und das meine Damen
und Herren ist verantwortungslos
gegenüber den Bürgern unseres Landes
wir können also trotz unserer
Befürwortung von internationalem Handel
und das möchte ich noch mal ausdrücklich
betonen dem Abkommen in dieser Form
aufgrund der von uns ausgemachten Mängel
nicht zustimmen vielen herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
das Wort hat Dr Lukas Köhler für die
FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Kollege
Riexinger hat eben gesagt dass wir für
ungebremsten Freihandel stehen würden
und dafür einsetzen und das klang so als
ob das was Schlechtes wäre nein im
Gegenteil ist es genau das richtige es
ist genau das was wir jetzt tun müssen
mehr Freiheit mehr internationale
Zusammenarbeit mehr wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung und ja mit den richtigen
Freunden mit Kanada wir reden heute über
Kanada ich möchte das noch mal eine
Erinnerung rufen ein Land das jetzt
nicht gerade besonders undemokratisch
ist oder von autoritären
Führungsstrukturen geprägt im Gegensatz
zu dem was sich die AFD anscheinend ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher was Sie sich
vorstellen weil das nicht so klar war
aber mehr Freihandel mehr Handel mit
Russland scheint der Weg zu sein den sie
wollen aber nicht sinnvollen Freihandel
wie ein Abkommen mit Kanada
dieses Land ist nach der Debatte um ttip
in einen handelspolitischen Tiefschlaf
verfallen die Union hat diesen
Tiefschlaf irgendwie ganz besonders mit
angeführt weil es kam einfach nicht in
den letzten Jahren und jetzt lehnen sie
und wir haben es gerade gehört auch noch
einen ein Ausschuss ein Unterausschuss
für Handel ich frage mich wo da die
handelspolitische Agenda der Union ist
klar und wichtig ist doch dass wir ein
Abkommen wie ceta jetzt voll umständlich
vollumfänglich ratifiziert und der Punkt
kann ja nicht die SPD gewesen sein sonst
würden sie es ja jetzt ablehnen sonst
werden sie jetzt dagegen ich glaube man
sieht und das hat haben die
Verhandlungen ganz eindeutig gezeigt
dass wir gemeinsam Dinge schaffen und
dass wir gemeinsam dafür sorgen können
dass es mehr Freihandel gibt mehr
Möglichkeiten diese Welt gemeinsam zu
gestalten und deswegen ist heute ein
guter Tag sein Tag der Zeitenwende weil
wir zeigen dass die richtigen Partner an
der richtigen Stelle mit uns zusammen
ich glaube aber es genug der Geschicht
auf Arbeit da haben wir genug von ich
glaube wir müssen jetzt über die Zukunft
und klar ist doch wir brauchen eine
Antwort auf den Inflation reduction Act
der USA aber diese Antwort darf doch
nicht sein dass wir jetzt in
handelspolitische Streitigkeiten nein
die haben die Antwort darf nicht sein
dass wir uns darüber aufregen dass die
USA in Zukunftstechnologien investieren
dass die USA sagen ja wir wollen mehr
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass wir über
Freihandel über ein neues Abkommen mit
den USA dafür kämpfen dass unsere
Unternehmen teilhaben an dieser
Entwicklung an der globalen Entwicklung
Richtung mehr Zukunftstechnologien in
Richtung mehr
wirtschaftlichen Wachstum Richtung mehr
Prosperität und das ist der Punkt und
das ist die Idee hinter diesen Mann
und ja natürlich haben wir neben dem
Freihandelsabkommen mit ceta in der
handelsagenda noch weitere Punkte
aufgegriffen wir reden über ein
transatlantischen Wirtschaftsraum wir
reden darüber mit Chile und Mexiko
gemeinsam zu arbeiten darüber dass die
jetzt ratifiziert werden können wir
reden darüber dass wir nicht nur mit den
USA in ein neues Freihandelsabkommen
eintreten sondern dass wir jetzt auch
mit merkurso die Gespräche beginnen weil
jetzt gerade die Wahl gezeigt hat dass
jetzt das Möglichkeiten Fenster dafür
offen ist und das sind die nächsten
großen Schritte die Diskussion in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten wird sein
wie kommen wir schnell vorwärts weil die
die sehr viel Diversifizierung dieser
Welt unserer Partner die darf nicht
weniger bedeuten neue China Strategie
darf nicht weniger handeln mit China
bedeuten sondern sie muss mehr mit
anderen Partnern mit neuen Partnern
bedeuten und das ist der Ansatz den wir
verfolgen das ist der Ansatz dieser
Ampel und das ist das was Deutschland
und unsere Wirtschaft braucht
wir reden wir sprechen und wir sorgen
für Investitionsschutz Deutschland hat
147 Investitionsschutzabkommen wie
nationaler Art wir kommen jetzt in
dieser Krise in dieser Phase in eine
neue Bewegung in eine neue Zeit in der
wir dafür sorgen dass die Unternehmen
die unter dem
energiecharter Vertrag investiert waren
auch noch 20 Jahre lang weiter
Investitionsschutz haben werden aber wir
müssen darüber nachdenken wie der
Investitionsschutz in Zukunft kommt und
der wird als etwas Schlechtes
dargestellt nein Investitionsschutz
bedeutet dass Unternehmen die bei uns
investieren oder unsere Unternehmen
anderen Ländern investieren dass die
geschützt sind das für die Recht und
Gesetz geht nach klaren Regeln nach
politischen Ideen aber vor allen Dingen
dafür dass wir gemeinsam wachsen und das
ist die handelsagender dieser
Bundesregierung das ist die
handelsagenter dieses Parlament ist dass
wir heute beschließen werden ich freue
mich darauf vielen Dank
[Applaus]
das Wort hat der Kollege Bernd Westphal
für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
einigen geht das nicht schnell genug mit
ceta und das ist manchmal so wie
Weihnachten ab das gestern in
Wirtschaftsausschuss schon gesagt dann
steigt halt die Spannung und alle können
es kaum erwarten aber wenn dann
Weihnachten da ist wird alles Gute alle
freuen sich und so ist das heute am 1
dezember 2022 werden wir hier im
Bundestag mit einer großen Mehrheit ceta
auf den Weg bringen das ist ein guter
Tag für unsere Wirtschaft
die Frage ist ja immer was schreibt man
in solche Verträge rein ja mein riesen
Umfang und es ist kompliziert und
komplex und deshalb ist das auch
manchmal schwierig das in der
gesellschaftlichen Debatte zu erklären
aber uns als Sozialdemokraten ist es
wichtig nicht nur Zölle Tarife Standard
zu entwickeln und dementsprechend auch
Formulare mit mit einer großen
Administration an Zeugen zu reduzieren
sondern uns kommt es darauf an dass wir
in dem nachhaltigkeitskapitel in einem
fortschrittlichen freiheitsabkommen auch
die Werte die uns sozial und ökologisch
in Europa verbinden mit verankern und
das ist hier in diesem Vertrag wunderbar
gelungen und deshalb ist ein gutes
Abkommen den wir heute den Weg frei
machen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
unsere Wirtschaft ist zum großen Teil
exportorientiert und deshalb sind es die
Beschäftigten die Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmern die in diesem Branchen
arbeiten und das ist nicht nur die große
Industrie sondern das ist auch
Mittelstand sind innovative Produkte die
auf dem globalen Weltmarkt Zugang zu
diesen Märkten haben müssen und die
unterstützen wir heute es sind genau
diese Arbeitsplätze die in Deutschland
abgesichert werden eben weil der Zugang
zu Märkten frei ist und deshalb ist
dieses Handelsabkommen wichtig für
unseren Wirtschaftsstandort
was wir aber auch mit der vereinbaren
ist das Handeln nicht nur frei ist
sondern fair wir haben immer gesagt in
den Kriterien das muss eine Rolle
spielen und deshalb war es auf den
letzten Metern auch richtig dass gerade
dann wenn es um den Schutz von
Investoren geht auch dann wenn es
Streitigkeiten gibt nicht hinter
verschlossenen Türen sondern in
öffentlichen bestellten
gerichtssählen das verhandelt wird und
das ist auch ein Fortschritt wenn man
sagen kann in dem Bereich wirklich ein
Benchmark gesetzt dass wir auch jetzt in
zukünftigen Handelsverträgen und daran
orientieren können diese
handelsgerichtshilfe die sorgen für
diese Transparenz die auch in der
breiten Gesellschaft dafür sorgen dass
solche Handelsverträge keine Bedrohung
sind sondern wirklich ein Fortschritt
und als letztes will ich sagen wir haben
eine schwierige Debatte gehabt was ttip
angeht und in diesem in dieser Zeit war
auch ceta die Verhandlung mit Kanada
aber ich will auch allen danken die dazu
beigetragen haben und ich glaube das ist
großer Konsens hier im Parlament auch
die Union hat ihren Antrag zurückgezogen
als erledigt erklärt und wird sicherlich
heute auch dem zustimmen und ich finde
in diesen Zeiten in diesen
geopolitischen Veränderungen ist es gut
dass eine breite parlamentarische
Mehrheit für diese Rahmenbedingungen
sorgt dafür herzlichen Dank Glückauf
hat der Kollege Stefan rauenhoff für die
CDU CSU-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist soweit
endlich die Ampel ratifiziert ceta
eigentlich selbstverständlich müsste man
meinen aber die Grünen brauchen für
solche Erkenntnisse ja immer ein
bisschen länger und wenn ich mir die
Reden der Koalition und insbesondere der
Grünen heute anschaut dann glaubt man
wirklich man ist hier in der
Märchenstunde als im Jahr 2016 die
Entscheidung zur vorläufigen Anwendung
von ceta auf der Brüsseler Tagesordnung
stand sind viele führende Politiker der
Grünen in Berlin und Brüssel gegen das
Abkommen auf die Straße gegangen das
haben wir vorhin schon gehört Annalena
baerbock Toni Hofreiter und Anton
Hofreiter der Fraktionsvorsitzende
frühere Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen
sei mit Zitat massiven Eingriffen in die
Demokratie und kommunale
Selbstverwaltung Zitat Ende Katharina
dröge hier heute sitzend als
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen
bezeichnete ceta als schlechtes Abkommen
und sie erklärte weiter Zitat zu viele
Punkte des Abkommens sind nachteilig für
VerbraucherInnen genauso wie für
Kommunen für unsere Demokratie und
unsere Standards die oft kritisierten
klageprivilegien sind dabei nur ein
Punkt Zitat Ende
2016 erklärten die Grünen in ihrer
Bundes in ihrem bundestagsantrag gegen
ceta
es sei sogar ein gefährliches Abkommen
meine Damen und Herren der grüne
Populismus in der Handelspolitik hat die
Menschen in unserem Land in hohem Maße
verunsichern auf die Bäume getrieben zu
Protesten gegen ceta und andere
Handelsabkommen bewegt und jetzt wo die
Menschen auf den Bäumen sind wo sie in
Regierungsverantwortung sind müssen sie
die Menschen wieder von dem Bäumen
runterholen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von den Grünen sie wollen den
Menschen in Deutschland heute
tatsächlich die Geschichte erzählen aus
einem ich verwende ihre Wortwahl
gefährlichen Abkommen nun ein faires
gutes Abkommen gemacht zu haben mit
Hilfe der von ihnen forcierten
interpretationserklärung zum Väter
Vertragstext also diese
Selbstdarstellung ist gelinde gesagt
schon sehr sehr mutig fangen wir mal mit
dem ersten Punkt an auch wenn ihnen die
kanadische Regierung positive Signale
gegeben haben sollte Ihre
interpretationserklärung
gemischten Ausschuss ist noch nicht ist
noch nicht im gemischten Ausschuss
behandelt worden und sie steht nach
unserer Kenntnis auch nicht auf der
Tagesordnung des morgigen gemeinsam
gemischten cetaausschusses zweiter Punkt
meine Damen und Herren
interpretationserklärung zum
Handelsabkommen scheinbar den Grünen
zumindest bis zur Übernahme von
Regierungsverantwortung keinen Mehrwert
zu haben die damalige grüne
handelsexpertin hier
Fraktionsvorsitzende Katharina dröge
erklärte in der Bundestagsdebatte am 22
September 2016 zu den damals
verabschiedeten Protokollerklärung zu
ceta Zitat
Protokollerklärung sind Interpretation
dessen was schon im Vertragstext steht
mehr nicht und genauso ist es liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die vorliegende
interpretationserklärung wiederholt in
anderer Form nur noch einmal das was
ohnehin schon im Vertragstext enthalten
ist das haben wir die
Sozialdemokraten gestern im Ausschuss
gesagt haben die FDP hat die FDP auch
gesagt damit ist die Erklärung also de
facto überflüssig vielleicht nicht für
die Grünen Wähler aber in der Sache und
um den ganzen noch einen drauf zu setzen
die Grünen wollten die von ihnen
vorangetriebene interpretationserklärung
nun ausgerechnet im gemischten
zetaausschuss also in jedem Gremium
verabschieden welches sie 2016 in ihrer
in ihrem bundestagsantrag gegen ceta
Zitat keine ausreichende demokratische
Legitimation attestierten das ist schon
ganz schön starker Tobak kommen Sie
bitte zum Schluss und meine Damen und
Herren heute ist nicht der Tag des
überschwangs ja und der Selbstsicherung
sondern ein Tag der Demut wir können
froh sein dass die Kanadier die
parteipolitischen Spielchen der
deutschen grünen mitgemacht haben danke
schön
stefan rohnhoff war das für die
Unionsfraktion
einen Besucher auf der Tribüne einen
schönen guten Tag von meiner Seite und
wir führen in der Debatte vor der
nächste Redners für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Jürgen Trittin
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
so Schicksal der Opposition schmutzige
Lieder singen zu müssen wenn sie wie
heute passieren wird der Regierung
zustimmen und dass sie so ein Aufwand
dafür betreiben dass überrascht dann
schon
ich wollte eine Bemerkung machen die
vielleicht etwas jenseits der reinen
Handelspolitik liegt weil der Kollege
Riexinger das ja auch angesprochen hat
Handelsabkommen haben auch eine
geostrategische Bedeutung
und deswegen ist die Frage das ist bei
ceta eine bedeutende Frage
was war ceta
ist abgeschlossen worden in einer
Situation
in der Kanada durch die USA massiv
erpresst wurde es gab nämlich ein
ungleichgewichtiges Handelsabkommen
damals noch NAFTA das benutzt worden ist
übrigens um die Kanadier in einer Weise
zu erpressen das war nicht mehr schön
und in diese geostrategische Situation
hat Europa eine Antwort gegeben die
gesagt wir wollen den Handel mit
Kanada stärken das ist übrigens auch im
Grundsatz auch von uns immer so als
richtig angesehen worden
und jetzt haben wir sechs Jahre Praxis
dabei
und nach sechs Jahren kommen jetzt zwei
Dinge hinzu es treten die Regelungen in
Kraft die den Arbeitsmarkt betreffen
also Schutzregeln und es treten die
veränderten Regeln was die Anwendung von
außergerichtlichen Schiedsverfahren
angeht in Kraft und das ist der Kern
dessen worüber wir heute abstimmen
en dann will ich aber noch einen
weiteren Punkt nach vorne sagen
hier ist der Vereinbarung genannt worden
dass die EU sondieren soll ob auf Seiten
der USA die Bereitschaft zu neuen
Verhandlungen und einem fairen Handel
besteht da steht nicht drin das kommt da
steht drin wir sondieren das und es
steht drinnen es ginge darum Markt
Zugangsbarrieren für
Zukunftstechnologien besonders bei
dekarbonisierung und anderen abzubauen
und da sind wir jetzt an einem Punkt wo
ich glaube wir vor einer ernsten
Herausforderung als Deutschland und als
Europäische Union stehen ich habe es
sehr begrüßt dass die beiden
Administrationen dieses Paket zur
Klimaschutz in den USA auf dem Weg
gebracht hat das umfasst das größte
Investitionsprogramm in der Geschichte
der USA was erneuerbare Energien
klimaschutztechnologie und Wasserstoff
angeht 400 Milliarden Dollar
aber es beinhaltet auch
marktzugangsbeschränkungen die aus
blanker Industriepolitik man könnte aus
auch sagen bei American besteht das ist
die Herausforderung vor der wir hier in
Europa stehen und all diejenigen die
jetzt mal eben locker davon reden da hat
man morgen ein Handelsabkommen sage ich
wir werden zu solchen Vereinbarungen nur
kommen wenn wir gleichzeitig uns in die
Lage versetzen auf ähnlich und Augenhöhe
damit zu spielen was ist also bei uns in
Europa mit einem European Server relativ
fand wo wir gegen diese Regeln ein
Gegengewicht machen und ich sage Ihnen
an dieser Diskussion werden wir nicht
vorbeikommen und wahrscheinlich werden
wir genau da landen wo auch die USA
gelandet sind als es um die Frage der
Finanzierung dieses Paket
zu 100% Kredit finanziert
und zu seiner ersten Rede im Deutschen
Bundestag erteile ich das Wort dem
Kollegen Alexander Barz SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer ich
bin erst seit wenigen Wochen
Abgeordneter dieses Hauses und bis vor
wenigen Wochen habe ich die
zeitdiskussion da ja auch nur von der
besucherbank aus betrachten können aus
dieser Sicht hat es mich ehrlich gesagt
häufig ein wenig gewundert warum wir bei
diesem Abkommen jahrelang so gespalten
waren da blickt man einmal zurück es gab
auch Zeiten lange ist es her da wurde
ceta noch nicht kritisch hinterfragt
erst als der damalige amerikanische
Präsident Barack Obama und die große
Koalition dann anfingen ttip zu
diskutieren da wurde plötzlich alles
anders Zeta wurde mit ttip
gleichgestellt ab diesem Moment standen
er nicht mehr die nüchternen Interessen
an dem Handelsabkommen im Vordergrund
nein das chlorhühnchen wurde zum Synonym
eines unzulänglichen Handelssystems
die Emotionalität dieser Zeit ließ keine
weitere wirkliche offene Diskussion mehr
zu diese Voraussetzung haben sich heute
zum Glück geändert und ich bin froh dass
wir nach langen und ausgiebigen
Diskussionen mit der heutigen Zustimmung
endlich einen richtigen und wichtigen
Schritt für einen wertbasierten Handel
machen können
der Großteil des täterhandelsvertrages
mit Kanada wird bereits seit 2017
vorläufig angewendet und ist quasi schon
gängige Praxis
die zuvor lange herbeige redeten
negativen Folgen für die Wirtschaft den
Verbraucher und die Umwelt sind bis
jetzt ausgeblieben
und wenn ich hier zum beispielsweise die
heimische Landwirtschaft in meinem
Wahlkreis Cloppenburg Vechta betrachtete
so ist es durch die bilateralen Abkommen
mit Japan und eben dem betrachteten
ceta-abkommen mit Kanada nicht zu
Überschwemmungen an Produkten aus diesen
Ländern in unseren heimischen
Supermärkten und auf unseren heimischen
Märkten gekommen sowohl in Japan als
auch in Kanada herrschen vergleichsweise
hohe Standards und es entstehen durch
die Verträge gute Absatzmöglichkeiten
für eine Vielzahl von wirtschaftlichen
Produkten
die Ratifizierung von ceta ist ein
wichtiger Schritt für ein vielfältiges
Investitions für vielfältige
investitions- und Handelsbeziehungen
zwischen der EU und Kanada und es ist
wichtig dass wir diese ausbauen und
weiter festigen
seitzeter angewendet wird
konnten konnte das güterhandelsvolumen
um rund 20 Prozent gesteigert und 98
Prozent der industriezäule abgeschafft
werden das bedeutet das seit dem
jährlich 590 Millionen Euro an
kanadischen Zollgebühren Wegfallen der
ratifizieren heute das ceta
Freihandelsabkommen mit Kanada 16
Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen Union
haben das bereits getan erst wenn alle
Mitgliedstaaten ratifiziert haben kann
das Abkommen vollständig in Kraft treten
wir haben heute also die Chance ein
wichtiges Signal Richtung Europa und für
den diversifizierten Freihandel zu legen
vielen Dank
Alexander Barz war das war seine erste
Rede denn er ist gerade erst nachgerückt
in den Bundestag für den ehemaligen
Abgeordneten Falko ist nämlich seit 8
November Minister für Wissenschaft und
Kultur in Niedersachsen
Andreas nein Bernhard los spricht nun
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
endlich endlich
kaum glaubt man es man kann es auch
leider nicht oft genug wiederholen
endlich nach Monaten der bewussten
Verschleppung kommt die Ampel zur
richtigen Einsicht ja Erleuchtung möchte
man sagen endlich nach jahrelangen
verfassungsrechtlichen vorbehaltene SPD
die wir als Union in der großen
Koalition hinnehmen mussten endlich nach
einer bisher grundsätzlichen Ablehnung
des Freihandels durch die Grünen wollen
sie als Ampel jetzt den Durchbruch
geschafft haben aber die Wahrheit ist
doch wer eine jahrelange ideologisch
geprägte Blockade endlich aufgibt der
ist noch lange kein Held des Freihandels
ich verstehe ja das vor allem für die
grüne Basis noch ein Placebo in Form von
angeblich substanziellen
vertragsverbesserungen durch eine
Protokollerklärung gefunden werden
musste aber in Wahrheit ist es doch nur
weiße Salbe wenn es den überhaupt so
kommt Deutschland war und ist eine große
Exportnation da ist es der freie Handel
für unser Land von herausragender
Bedeutung wir als Union stehen als
voller Überzeugung seit jeher für
multilateralen Handel und
Freihandelsabkommen und wenn wir heute
den multilateralen Handel gefährdet
sehen durch die Schaffung von
geopolitischen in Einfluss werden dann
sind Freihandelsabkommen umso wichtiger
hätten die Grünen nicht ttips so
diskreditiert und ceta bisher
ideologisch verhindert dann stimmten
Deutschland und die EU heute viel besser
abgesicherter auch vor dem Hintergrund
des neuen
us-inflationsbekämpfungsgesetzes dass er
unter dem Deckmantel der Klimapolitik
stark protektionistische Züge trägt aber
unsere Antwort darauf kann ich sein
selbst in Protektionismus zu verfallen
nein wir müssen mit den USA weiter und
noch intensiver ins Gespräch kommen die
transatlantischen Beziehungen sind für
uns als CDU CSU in viele Hinsicht
besonders bedeuten denn wir teilen mit
den USA die westlichen Grundlagen von
der Freiheit des Individuums der
Freiheit des Denkens der Freiheit der
Gesellschaft und der Freiheit der
Wirtschaften des Handels
das eine kann es nicht ohne das andere
geben nun geht es mit der beiden
Regierung Schwung in die EU
us-wirtschaftsbeziehung zu bringen dazu
listet unser Antrag eine Vielzahl
konkreter Forderungen Möglichkeiten auf
wir wollen auf EU-Ebene mit den USA eine
positive Agenda voranbringen die die
großen Chancen in der
digitalwettbewerbspolitik bei
Technologiefragen sowie im Energie-
den Handel und technologie- erfolgreich
entwickeln auch unter einer möglichen
Einbeziehung Japans
eine Neustart von Verhandlungen über
handelswirtschaftsinvestitionsabkommen
welche auch klimapolitische Maßstäbe
besetzt
eine Stärkung des regelbasierten Handels
ist ein entscheidend wichtig die wtu
muss durch eine umfassende Reform und
eine funktionierende
streitbeteiligungsmechanismus wieder an
Bedeutung gewinnen aber lassen Sie mich
auch unterstreichen wir als Union wollen
die Handelspolitik klar Wirtschaft und
handelspolitisch ausrichten nicht mit
anderen sachfremden Themen überfrachten
offene Märkte und freier regelbasierter
Handel sind die Fundamente für
dauerhaftes Wachstum für sichere
Beschäftigung und steigenden Wohlstand
weltweit vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Andreas larem
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen lassen Sie mich
eine außenpolitische Sichtweise auf Sita
das freihandsabkommen mit Kanada
einnehmen das Abkommen soll unsere
Wirtschafts- und Handelsbeziehung
zwischen der Europäischen Union und
Kanada vertiefen gerade vor dem
Hintergrund des brutalen russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine und
der damit verbundenen Zeitenwende müssen
wir unsere Beziehung mit unseren
internationalen Partnern verstärken in
diesem Sinne begrüße ich es dass wir
heute die Ratifizierung des Abkommens
diskutieren und abstimmen denn Kanada
ist für uns ein wichtiger Partner für
fairen und freien Handel mit Kanada
teilen wir die Werte der Demokratie der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und eine offenen und
fairen Gesellschaft deshalb ist es
gerade jetzt ein wichtiges Zeichen wenn
wir als Europäische Union den Handel mit
unseren
Ängsten verbünden und westlichen
Partnern verlässlichen Partnern
intensivieren
den Seitenwände heißt auch dass wir
unsere demokratischen Allianzen auf
politischer und auch wirtschaftlicher
Ebene Stärken dabei freue ich mich
besonders dass die maßgeblichen
Veränderungen die im Rahmen der
Nachverhandlungen zu cita erreicht
wurden eine deutliche
sozialdemokratische Handschrift tragen
dazu
zählt zum einen der
öffentlich-rechtliche
investitionsgerichtshof mit der
unabhängigen Richterinnen und Richtern
ausgestattet ist und zum anderen der
besondere Schutz der Daseinsvorsorge für
Privatisierung meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren mit Zita schaffen wir nun die
Grundlage für die notwendige
Diversifizierung unserer Wirtschaft denn
wir müssen unsere wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen breite aufstellen und
politische Abhängigkeiten von
Einzelstaaten reduzieren deshalb setzen
wir auch auf setzen wir uns auch für
einen zügigen Abschluss der
Verhandlungen über die Handelsverträge
der EU mit Chile und Mexiko ein wir
wollen in Zukunft nach unserer
Handelsbeziehungen grundsätzlich
ausbauen auch mit den USA so gibt es für
das
merkurabkommen nach den Wahlen in
Brasilien eine neue Möglichkeit ein
Fenster und da ich Anfang des Monats
gerade in Südostasien war kann ich Ihnen
bestätigen auch dort gibt es große
Interessen
in angesichts der multiplan
Herausforderung
das Gebot der Stunde das ist gut klug
und richtig herzlichen Dank
und auch der nächste Redner ist von der
SPD und er sagt der letzte Redner bevor
wir hier zu den Abstimmungen zum
Handelsabkommen ceta kommen
für die SPD-Fraktion
der Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach fünf
Jahren der vorläufigen Anwendung bin ich
froh dass wir heute endlich politische
Klarheit zu schaffen in dieser Zeit
haben wir die Welt hat sich die Welt und
unsere Prioritäten grundlegenden
verändert die Ernährung liberale
Irrglaube vom Wohlstand und
wirtschaftlicher Stabilität durch immer
mehr der Regulierung ist endgültigen
gescheitert die Pandemie hat globale
Lieferketten langfristige stört und
schon droht in China die nächste Krise
der russische Angriffskrieg hat uns
unsere kritischen Abhängigkeit
schmerzhaft vor Augen geführt
und zunehmend zunehmende
Extremwetterereignisse machen uns
deutlich dass ohne Klimaschutz und
Nachhaltigkeit als politische
Prioritäten unsere Versorgung Sicherheit
und zivilisatorische und
zivilisatorische Rolle überleben akut
gefährdet sind Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Markt regelt eben nicht von allein
Industrie und Handel brauchen für den
langfristigen Erfolg einen Kompass von
klarer politischer Prioritäten setzen
Sitzung und Leitplanken es hat dabei
nun eine gewisse Ironie das ausgerechnet
ein Freihandelsabkommen einen wichtigen
Schritt in diesem Paradigmenwechsel
darstellt siehta bedeutet genau das
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
stärken damit nicht nur unsere
Verbindungen so Kanada als wichtige und
verlässliche handelspartnerin in einen
instabilen Wert Kanada ist das
europäische Land außerhalb Europas mein
Kollege Bernd brützel wir zeichnen damit
vor allem eine Blaupause für eine neue
Generation von Handelsabkommen so
konnten wir im heutigen Entwurf
grundlegende Verbesserungen beim
schwierigen Thema des
investitionsschutzes erreichen und mit
der Review Klausel steht darüber hinaus
das Fenster offen für grundsätzliche
Fortschritte so könnten wir
beispielsweise die
kernarbeitsformen der Iller das Pariser
Klimaabkommen oder künftig auch die
biodiversitätsabkommen nicht nur als
standardsfest fahren kann sondern sie
auch durch handfeste
Sanktionsmöglichkeiten durchsetzen
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss
zu ergreifen ich bitte um ihre
Zustimmung vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
und damit schließe ich die Aussprache
und wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den
von der Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zu dem umfassenden
Wirtschaft und Handelsabkommen ceta vom
30 Oktober 2016 zwischen Kanada
einerseits und der Europäische Union und
ihren Mitgliedsstaaten andererseits der
Wirtschaftsausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe a seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache 47/31 den Gesetzentwurf
der Bundesregierung auf Drucksache 34 43
anzunehmen die Fraktion der cdu/csu hat
dazu namentliche Abstimmung verlangt es
liegen uns auch mehrere Erklärungen zur
Abstimmung gemäß Paragraph 31 Absatz 1
unserer Geschäftsordnung vor
unmittelbar nach der Eröffnung der
namentlichen Abstimmung werden wir noch
weitere Abstimmungen durchführen ich
bitte Sie deshalb hier noch im Saal zu
bleiben die Abstimmung erfolgt in der
westlobby und sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer
Stimme nach der Eröffnung der Abstimmung
20 Minuten Zeit ich bitte die
Schriftführerin und Schriftführer die
vorgesehenen Plätze einzunehmen ich sehe
dass die Urnen besetzt sind und ich
eröffne hier mit die namentliche
Abstimmung über den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung die Abstimmungen die
abstimmungsurnen werden um 13 Uhr
geschlossen das bevorstehen also die
Abgeordneten also das sehen Sie
vielleicht kriegen hier auch von der
jeweils angezeigt wie ihre Fraktion
abstimmt denn natürlich
wird man sich hier an den
Fraktionszwang halten auch wenn
natürlich die Abgeordneten frei werden
ihrem Gewissen dort zu folgen und hier
haben wir auch schon zum Beispiel
gesehen von der afd-fraktion gab es hier
schon eine rote Karte die hier hoch
gehalten wurde das heißt die
Abgeordneten werden hier dem
Gesetzentwurf nicht zustimmen und damit
wird sich die afd-fraktion verhalten wie
auch die Linksfraktion auch in der
Linksfraktion gab es hier schon das
Zeigen der roten stimmenkarte also auch
eine Ablehnung von der Linksfraktion die
ampelfraktionen werden sich
wahrscheinlich davon können wir mal
ausgehen mit einer blauen Karte hier
beteiligen das bedeutet Zustimmung für
diesen Gesetzentwurf
und bei der Unionsfraktion könnte es
dann blau auch geben eine Zustimmung
sollten sich hier Abgeordnete enthalten
wollen dann können Sie eine weiße
Stimmkarte einwerfen all das findet hier
nicht im Plenarsaal statt sondern in der
westlobby das wird hier weiterhin so
gehalten um den Abstand zu wahren
schließungsantrag abgelehnt
wir setzen die Abstimmung zur
Beschlussempfehlung des
Wirtschaftsausschusses auf Drucksache 47
31 fort der Ausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe c seiner Beschlussempfehlung
den gleich lautenden Gesetzentwurf der
ampelfraktionen auf Drucksache 25 69 für
erledigt zu erklären wer stimmt für
diese Beschlussempfehlung
das ist das gesamte Haus wer stimmt
dagegen niemand Enthaltung auch keine
dann ist die Hintergrund ist her dass es
einen
wortgleichen an Gesetzentwurf der
Fraktionen gab dass diese Mittel nutzen
die Fraktionen hier von Zeit zu Zeit um
Gesetzentwürfe beschleunigt beraten zu
können aber weil es nun eben hier auch
zur Abstimmung über den Gesetzentwurf
der Bundesregierung gekommen ist hat man
diesen hier für nicht dich erklärt und
Haltung gegen Probe oder sehe ich nicht
dann ist ja bestimmt die
Beschlussempfehlung so angenommen wir
kommen zum Tagesordnungspunkt 9 c der
Wirtschaftsausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe e seiner beschlusser
Empfehlung auf Drucksache 47 31 die
Ablehnung des Antrages der Fraktion der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache zehn zehn mit dem
Titel Europas wettbe und Fähigkeit
erhalten die Wirtschaft und
handelspolitischen Beziehungen im
atlantischen Raum Stärken wer stimmt für
diese Beschlussempfehlung die
Ampelkoalition und die Fraktion DIE
LINKE wer stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu wer enthält sich die
afd-fraktion die Beschlussempfehlung ist
damit angenommen und das bedeutet dass
der Antrag der Unionsfraktion abgelehnt
wurde